I think they're looking at jail the
Democrat leadership
they're they're not looking at just
losing an election and I think they know
that because once you say you know Trump
we're going to put you in actual jail
and we're trying as hard as we can to do
it the gloves are off there's nothing to
keep Trump from saying all right if I
can find any ridiculous reason that you
broke a law we're not going to play the
old rules where if it isn't a good
reason you don't pursue it because
that's not the way they played so in a
way I think he may have brought it on
himself his very first statement about
uh Hillary Clinton should be in jail I I
feel like when he started talking real
jail then politics changed and they said
if you're going to talk real jail for us
we're actually going to put you in jail
and it looks like that's what's
happening so we don't really know how
things really run behind the garden but
you know if you're just judging from the
few things you can see it does look like
somebody else is in charge
and that somebody else has very specific
ideas about who should be in charge and
if you look at the the totality of the
coordinated actions it has every sign of
somebody trying to cover up their own
crimes
as in whoever's really in charge doesn't
want anybody investigating them either
so I feel like it's called what do you
mean what what signs what what uh what
crimes what are you talking about
well whoever would back Biden is doing
it out of desperation not because they
think it's a good idea so who who acts
out of desperation if you say well it's
the team thing they just they want their
team to win but this feels way beyond
that
team win would be Gavin Newsom already
already running now what I think they
want is they well in 2020 they wanted a
guy
who could unite because she was so kind
of middle and Bland who could unite the
Democrats and not offend the demo any
Democratic voters so that Trump lost
that's what they wanted right well that
was the story but don't you think they
could have found a hundred Bland people
to do that I mean bland is pretty easy
to find what they found he was vice
president he had name recognition you
know all right all right he's been in
the game a long time as well but
consider the alternative explanation he
was the most connected to Obama and sort
of the Hillary Clinton part of the
machine that's the part of the machine
that seems to be in charge I don't know
what individuals but it seems like that
that Universe the people seem to be in
charge do you think they want somebody
who's not their guy
to be in that office they need their
guide to be in the office because that's
how they stay in charge or it was also
how they avoid any investigations into
anything they may have done so it feels
like not an election to find your your
best guy or woman it doesn't feel like
an election that's just team it it
screams two sides trying to stay on a
jail I mean honestly the only way I
think Trump stays out of jail is by
winning the election
you know you might you might literally
have to Pardon himself which I'd be fine
with
um and I think Biden might have to
Pardon himself and haunt her or at least
Hunter before he leaves so to me the
entire thing looks like Joe may be
trying to hold on to keep Hunter out of
jail you know to maintain his his pardon
ability but without pardoning him too
soon because then it affects the
election right so if if Joe I'm a pure
speculation I can't read minds but if
you put me in his situation if you say
all right you're Joe Biden what do you
do the first thing I do is make sure I
get to the second election get elected
and then I can pardon anybody I want
because I'm not running for election
then
so he might be limping to the you know
the Finish Line just to make sure Hunter
doesn't go to jail now that might be
everything we're seeing like it might
explain all observations a father trying
to keep his son out of jail because
that's going to Trump everything you
know no pun intended you know that's
going to be bigger than money it's going
to be bigger than winning it's going to
be bigger than team it's going to be
bigger than everything so and and is
there any way to keep Hunter out of
trouble unless Biden's in office
I don't see the second way
because I think he would be instantly
unprotected if Biden left office
foreign